ayudamos a las personas mujeres
positivas con VIH Lourdes Torres líder
de la asociación prodefensa de la mujer
se declara activista por los derechos de
las mujeres y busca apoyo ante la falta
de un marco jurídico de protección para
esta actividad en Ecuador mientras lo
consigue Lourdes ayuda también a las
familias de mujeres en situación de
prostitución un término que ella no
comparte y prefiere el de trabajadoras
sexuales es el caso de solange Benavides
a quien la asociación patrocinó sus
estudios luego del fallecimiento de su
madre una ex trabajadora sexual al
activismo de las trabajadoras sexuales
les debo mi educación
les debo un plata de comida que llegaba
a mi casa
mi mamá bueno con apoyo de la Señora
Lourdes Torres pudo salir del trabajo
sexual este día Lourdes asiste a una
audiencia en un tribunal de Quito para
presentar una acción de protección a
favor de cuatro mil de ellas un la
legalización y el reconocimiento del
trabajo sexual y de ber de ver que la de
la situación que también seamos parte
del seguro social y también de saber que
que tenemos el mismo derecho todo para
de ser una ciudad igual que todas
en un club nocturno funciona la
asociación María prepara la comida para
las mujeres antes de iniciar su jornada
en otro piso contiguo Natalia está a
cargo del desarrollo de programas piloto
enfocados en asesoría legal y apoyo a
quienes deseen abandonar la actividad en
el país según Natalia hay 70.000
establecimientos como los llama el
Ministerio de salud pública donde se
ejerce esta actividad la asociación
prodefensa de la mujer en sí lo que
hemos retomado es el tema de ayudar y
guiar a las chicas en el tema de
derechos Aunque la prostitución en
Ecuador no es ilegal no hay una
regulación de protección de sus derechos
sólo se practica en lugares denominados
casas de tolerancia lour después de una
que no garantizan la integridad física
psicológica o una vida libre de
violencia cada día Estas mujeres pueden
ser Víctimas de explotación sexual o
abuso de las autoridades